because of my
trauma
i
woke up from the greatest slumber
and i didn't that i didn't even know
that i was in
and so having the
humbling privilege of getting to work
with people
as they come back to more of who they
are
is i cannot
i cannot express the joy that that gives
me in words
like to see people
to see those lights go on in their head
when they remember
their body when they feel pleasure again
when they're able to lead from their
heart when men are able to not be afraid
of their emotions but recognize the
power
within them
when
a couple is able to for the first time
not be afraid of love
because they've finally mended those
wounds within themselves and are able to
meet another and that way like
i do
believe in my own personal experience
and with every survivor and with every
person i've ever met our greatest trauma
is always the key to our greatest
treasures
boom what's up everyone welcome to
simulation i'm your host alan sakyon we
are on site in los angeles in california
we are going to be talking about all
things sexual assault all things healing
all things coaching all things
spirituality
very excited blessed honored to have
koko mckenzie joining us on the show
hello
hi thank you for having me i really
appreciate it really excited for this
yeah thank you yes
coco has a really incredible background
and we'll be diving deep to all these
topics throughout this conversation
she's an inspirational speaker
she's a sexual assault survivor
she's a transformation master
and she's helped
people live most their most radiant
lives after sexual abuse
over hundreds of women over the last
three years
so
yeah this is a very there's a very
serious
show um but at the same time we have to
be play you know play as well and dance
but it's so it's it's a lot and it's
hard even for me to
to to to do like this it's just it's a
harder it's a harder topic and and
you know that's what i'm feeling right
now
and
yeah sexuality
i think for most people sexuality um
feels very heavy especially when you tie
in any layer of abuse
and
one of the most simplest truths is that
laughter is the best medicine
and that sexuality is meant to be
blissful and playful and shared and it
is not always and the healing path to it
is not always heavy and it is not always
serious so i appreciate your
vulnerability in saying that and
that's also part of the problem
is that we need to shift that
um reality
because when it is treated as so heavy
and so dense it kind of a lot of people
stay away or shy away from it
and that's the very opposite of what we
need because we're all sexual beings and
when one of us heals we all heal
so
just that right there is
is very interesting to me because like
you said sexuality is supposed to be
this
consensual uh incredible experience and
whenever the word abuse comes in just
the whole body's just like no
like that's so
not okay
and then
the way to get away from that density
when abuse does happen is through that
lighter
that's that is quite an interesting way
to to think about it and you you so you
you you you you're specialized in this
and i'm excited to to talk about this to
talk about this um
okay i want to i want to start we always
kind of start with a big history
perspective on civilization and
this will be interesting to hear how how
you are viewing things um yeah for me
too
you're like big history i'm like wait
what
okay lead me alan what do you wanna
so we find ourselves as stewards of
earth after a period long period of
evolution and yeah there's 7.7 billion
of us now and there's a lot of
complexity in the relationships between
humans and
i'm curious what is your synthesis on
this current state of humanity with all
the exponential technology and all of
the complexity between our relationships
and communications
oh
i
i
feel a little bit of an embarrassment
to say i don't
spend most of my time
considering like society at large i
think
my natural
where my thoughts naturally go is so
much more
micro
and so
in all of the
interactions i have
daily at a grocery store
in a yoga class i and with
so with every
micro interaction i have i
can see the the macro
um but i get it through an individual
experience so
what is the current state
we are i feel that we are isolated i
feel that we're alone i feel
that technology is a wonderful tool but
it is out of balance in a lot of
people's lives
um
so that i don't i don't know if i'm
really answering your questions you are
totally answering it yes and i found it
really interesting that you do you've
really become
you've become so specialized at the
micro at the nuance of the one-on-one
human emotional expression that maybe
um that's something that we can we can
see that certain people are focusing
more on that some people are focusing
more on some sort of a more abstract
demographical analysis of all of the
people on the planet so that's cool how
people can eb between those or
specialize in those but then yeah i
think it all blends perfectly together
like the world as we know it is
operating
as true like it is what it is you have
some people more focused on global scale
you have people more focused on
you know you global scale all the way
down to the immediate one-on-one and
it works
speaking of things that are out of
balance like you pointed out with
technology as a tool it's a little out
of balance you we also speak frequently
about how feminine energy there's
definitely an out of balance going on
but a kind of an uprising of effeminate
energy that's coming
and that's we're starting to feel that
it's feeling more
like earth energy it's feeling more
compassionate more heart centric that's
what it feels more like to me
and i want to hear about that because
that has a lot to do with
your practice i want to know about that
that balance that's a little
maybe off right now and how you feel it
sort of rising up
um
the balance i feel is off between
masculine and feminine yeah
um
well
it's a it's a give and a take and it
kind of goes back to what i was saying
about the separation
because we're all
have within us the masculine and
feminine energies it's giving and
receiving its um
um produce or rest it is
um the head and the heart
like we all
have that and so
i think as as
society evolves um we are getting we are
becoming more emotionally intelligent
um and
there is
women are creating more of a
women are stepping into more of our
fullness
and i know that that also requires for
men to step into theirs because you
can't have one without the other because
that masculine and feminine it's not i
don't view it as two separate things i
view it as a scale
so and that applies to like good and
evil black and white i view everything
as a scale
and so i feel like as a society we are
coming a little bit more back into
center
um
but
now you have to ask me a little more
about yeah yeah that's that's that's
right that's how i feel about
it as well on a on a scale i'm coming
more towards an
equilibrium now
this this is this is so
in my
in my
you know in very deep inexperience with
what
really with sex and relationships and
love
and
and
abuse this is a it's like it's it's a
quite a it's quite a beautiful yet
complicated thing as we were pointing
out earlier and
it can be dense it can be light it's
kind of
so so tell us about what it's been like
you know
working in this in this field leading up
to
um we'll go leading up to what was um
leading up to like 2012 but like what's
it been like working in the in the field
it's
it's been the greatest gift of my life
um i
because of my
trauma
i
woke up from the greatest slumber
and i didn't that i didn't even know
that i was in
and so having the
humbling privilege
of getting to work with people
as they come back to more of who they
are
is i cannot
i cannot express the joy that that gives
me in words like
to see people
to see those lights go on in their head
when they remember
their body when they feel pleasure again
when they're able to lead from their
heart when men are able to not be afraid
of their emotions but recognize the
power
within them
when
a couple is able to for the first time
not be afraid of love
because they've finally mended those
wounds within themselves and are able to
meet another and that way like
i do
believe in my own personal experience
and with every survivor and with every
person i've ever met our greatest trauma
is always the key to our greatest
treasures
and we are not without choice and we are
we absolutely have everything we need
to heal and to live in wholeness and it
is not an easy journey and again it's
because of that
the social conditioning
around
sexuality
men and women
vulnerability
um the processes
that we have
set up as a society and then the
heaviness that like as a result all of
that feels heavy to most people and so
we steer away from
our bodies our emotions our sexuality
and it keeps us numb
and then we have a society that is
disconnected and in pain and unable to
relate and have everything that they
want
um
because what we want is usually
you know locked behind
some very scary guarded door
scarily garden door i don't even know if
scarily is a word but i'm making it up
i need it to be weird right now so yeah
that that was whoa
behind our traumas are some of our
greatest treasures
i have always found that to be true
if
it is not
without
a like great dedication
to get to that point but i have seen
that if a person commits to themselves
their gift is like you get to it through
the path
of
pain suffering trauma
like
because again i believe everything is
one
so so your greatest fear and your
greatest desire it's the same thing
where are you on that scale
so if you're experiencing deep
depression and
fear of being intimate and
um
if you're to the level of pain that
you're experiencing that pendulum like
it has to swing equal and opposite the
other way if you're willing to do the
work
um and i i know for me
i
didn't see anyone in my life
do it like
i didn't i didn't have i wasn't raised
in a community where i could look at the
elders and go
i want my life to look like yours you're
like you're doing something right i
didn't have that and so growing up i
didn't there wasn't a
i wasn't given the tools to do that
and then through my trauma i was raped
in 2012.
i remember googling
what do you do when you're raped
and rain
um
was the only thing that really popped up
and
when you're inside of so much trauma
you're literally reduced to infancy
so i couldn't read
like i just saw a white screen with a
ton of black words and i was like i
like i don't know what to do with that
and what i needed was somebody to break
it down and to give me the tools
and
what
i've been blessed with now is is
wonderful people that have
taught me
and that's now what my whole life is
dedicated to is helping people
really really really
live a life that they love and it
doesn't matter what you've experienced
so
[Laughter]
yeah there's there's there's a lot there
there's there's there's you talking
about this
well what
what what is like
a a moment of of
of full like you said radiance that
comes on back online on on people when
they get to work through their trauma
and swing back over to that side of of
wholeness of
for themselves
and that is beautiful and that's so
important to have that you're catalyzing
that for others and that you're making
actually programs to do so at larger
scales which we'll which we'll talk
about and then through your own story
maybe you know to take us through your
own
swinging of your pendulum
oh god um
man i
the all the best way i've been able to
describe how i was immediately after the
assault was like the walking dead
i didn't
feel
i didn't feel alive
i couldn't
like i couldn't do anything i couldn't
sleep because i had nightmares of being
raped in every possible way that you
could
i
put this brick wall up around
my heart and around just around all of
life because i would feel like
i'd be going through
daily life and i would feel the emotions
start to come up and i
physically remember being like i like
push it down
like it felt like water like the dam was
gonna break and i didn't have the tools
to
process that
um
i
yeah it was it absolutely took the life
out of me
and because
of all of that it's also given me
everything that i have now but that's
been one hell of a journey
so
let's see um
uh
i mean
immediately after the assault
uh i went through
i got to file i chose to file with the
police
um i had a wonderful officer thank god
because you were thrown into an
interrogation room and that is the
scariest thing because all my
subconscious knows of an interrogation
room is when i'm watching a movie and
someone's in trouble
so i'm going into an interrogation room
going through
the you know official report and it
like i i just i could feel nothing like
the words were coming out of my mouth
but i did not feel alive it was
completely numb um
is that standard procedure
for reporting to be in an interrogation
room
yeah if you do it at the police station
yes you can
report
assault through um a doctor
um
through a therapist through a
gynecologist through
um i didn't know that at the time
yeah yeah this is the educational piece
to things yeah because getting to report
through your doctor
um you know another i just helped a
woman report and she um
went through her therapist i was there
her therapist was there and we called an
officer in so we were in a more safe
environment
like
your system is more calm yeah but i
didn't know that
you know it was my first time
so
now looking back i'm like [ __ ] i really
wish i had someone to walk me through it
um
so i was thrown into an interrogation
room i did the
i gave the full recount of what had
happened to me
um
which is hard like trauma it splits
inside so it splits the you know your
body from
your mind from your emotions and then it
also splits your mind into two so the
story of what happened
and
um like the effects and how you feel it
splits in your brain so it's why
oftentimes we sound like
we're not telling the truth
because your brain is literally split
and so in trying to recount the story
it's so hard because you're like
you can't remember all the details and
i felt really bad for
um
not remembering everything i was putting
a lot of pressure on myself
to
be able to give like a detailed bullet
pointed
recount of the experience and i couldn't
because my body as a
loving act
did this you know protective mechanism
of numbing me
so
i went through that i moved the police
officer took me to um
the hospital
which is where you meet with a
trained nurse to go through the rape kit
which is the forensic exam
and
that was the hardest part about being
raped
because i already felt
i hated my body
like i
felt him all over me it didn't feel like
my own body anymore i felt dead inside i
couldn't scrub my skin enough
and so to go into
you know to be driven in the back of a
cop car after being in an interrogation
room to
going through a forensic exam and then
dying my skin blue i felt like
a science experiment
and
i just checked out because i i couldn't
handle it
i had no clue what i was getting into
and i'm
very grateful
for that process now
but in the moment it was
hard
the government's also changed the rate
kit process to make it easier
but they did that after i already had
mine
driven in the back of a cop car
afterward to the hospital yeah
and
having
your skin dyed
blue to tell
it was
because you're having to tell the story
again because the
police report and then and the nurse
they haven't had time to
um sync up you're doing it again for the
nurse you have to re you i had to tell
them again
which just felt like it felt like a joke
to me because i was in so much pain and
i was so angry
having to like i was getting angry with
the nurse for making me tell her even
though
in hindsight she was doing her job and
she was helping me but i i i was too in
my own trauma to understand that
um
and it's hard like
it's a cold sterile room it feels you
feel like a science i felt like a
science experiment and they
like
they take photos of everything they take
skin swabs they ask you
you know
where on your body will there be the
most evidence
and you know for me that was
my vulva my anus my my back like
and so to to already be so violated and
then to have to sit there and do it
again
is really difficult
and
i wish i had known better
because there are things that you can do
to make that process easier and that
process is the biggest investment i made
in feeling powerful had i not reported
and gone through that rape kit i would
not
would not be able to heal the way that i
feel
like that gave me my voice it gave me my
power back it helped me to to stand
proud
it helped me to reconnect to my body
like
as hard as it was
it's been ten times better i and i
i don't want anyone to be
to avoid
the
more like
immediate hardship for
for a long term gain like
this was back in 2012
the system's gotten a little bit easier
since then and now we have women who are
creating systems
to help
because assault in america
happens every one minute and eight
seconds
and no one's talking about it
that's a lot yeah
yeah
ninety-five
go unreported
and i i is ninety-five percent 25 goes
unreported
i believe that our silence is that
because you like follow up with them
like like later in their life and ask
them and they said they didn't report it
is that how we know that statistic
it's on rain
this program
has evolved over time
but at the time when this was happening
um you yeah you had a limited amount of
of tools available for you or google
searching and
now
people like you are making the tools to
make this significantly
more
um
like you said you had empower like you
you gained power back by reporting it
and that was yeah and that's a huge part
of this
point and so is
having this k this
easily available kit
uh and
and like e-guide
like trying to guide to to help with
this process more easily
yeah i think
trauma happens when the system's shocked
so we need to reduce
shock
what i am creating is that it is a
a very simple breakdown of one of the
most difficult processes you could ever
go through
so
again
you can't like for me and for
all of the other
assault survivors that i've spoken with
worked with
and trauma specialists like we know
that the brain can't take in that much
information
after any level of abuse whether it's
sexual or not
so
the reason why i couldn't process reigns
system was it was just too much for me
um so i've created fresh which is
an
a free
e-guide and it's the immediate starting
point post-sexual abuse so there are
you know i teach you how to
the best practices for
filing for reporting an official um
for officially reporting for
and there's a rape kit guide what to
bring what to avoid what evidence is how
you store it where you submit it
how to tell someone and who to tell
um
practices to keep you calm
through the entire process
um
that and it's just
you know the checklists are like one to
two pages and so had i had that
it would have drastically limited or
reduced my um
the the trauma
um
and that's that's my hope and what it
does for others
yeah you you started you started this
list and this list is
you said you know checklist guide
preserving evidence how to file a good
report who to tell how to tell them yeah
how to remain calm these best healing
practices in a very like you said for
one of the most traumatic experiences a
simple breakdown of how to handle that
that's what to provide to people yeah
yeah and it's
with
such
deep humility
that i
create everything that i do because i
am not a doctor i
um
and i really understand that it's such a
personal journey
um
but as a survivor myself and as someone
who
bled walked and crawled her way back
to life like i speak and i create from
an honest vulnerable
sincere place and i don't claim that it
will
that it's perfect but i i but it's it's
got to be helpful
and that's my heart for it so
it's
i don't know
what's the
uh
are you are you comfortable talking
about the violation of consent that
happened
with the
with the yeah
yeah
for me yeah
um
for me
there wasn't any
he didn't have a consent
uh
so it was a complete and total violation
um
yeah i
and it was this how does someone do that
to someone else what was going on were
they intoxicated how does someone do
that
i have thought a lot about that
um
and the only explanation that
lands in my heart that feels true enough
for me to believe and like
put my life on
is that hurt people
hurt people
i know anything beyond that i i
don't know
so healing
hurtness can save a lot of
other people from being hurt
yeah
oh yeah i i believe
the ripple effects of one person like is
being hurt can just go and butterfly
effect out if that if that he if that's
not healed quickly yeah
yeah i mean
you can leave a word
hurt and healing have the same ripple
effect i believe
like if you're if you're hurt you're
having maybe a
more of like a slightly
negative ripple effect
and then if you're healed you can give
like a positive
ripple effect
yeah but it's it's one drop
for every healing act it's a drop for
every hurting act it's a drop
yeah yeah of of positivity or negativity
yeah okay okay
oh jeez
how you feeling
trying to stay light and
trying to stay light you can tell that
you after you know
seven years feel more
you know that you're doing the the work
and you know me i'm
i'm sitting here trying to make sure
that
that other
um
i don't know part part of me
part of me
is reminded about how i try and help
men sometimes realize that you know that
women
give birth and try and like get behind
the eyes of women that you know are
carrying a child within them for nine
months
and trying to help you know you're
trying to you know you're helping me
right now get behind the eyes of what
it's like to
to
you know
be
have your consent violated
in an abusive assaultive way and then go
into like an interrogation room with
cops and then a hospital like that's
just yeah and
science experimented that's this is you
know that i think stories like that can
can can drive more empathy for men to
to care more about
about listening
to care more about helping make sure
that other men don't you know violate
consent that they're
hold themselves to
account accountable for that
um there's like a kind of a
controversial like
controversial like
uh gillette ad that was
whoever did you ever see that
yeah gillette just played like an ad
that had uh um
like
trying to get rid of like toxic
masculinity and try and you know boost
up like good masculinity and then it
became kind of like a hit piece for some
conservatives to say that like screw
gillette you know
and like for me i thought there was a
lot more nuance to it like i thought
that it was actually like kind of
important in some ways for men to like
see that and say like yeah like i like
like i want to be i want to be held i
want to hold you know i want to hold
consent as something that i really care
about i want to help other guys you know
hold consent to something that they care
about
there was there's more nuance to it but
i think the consent
when i boil down
when i ask what is beneath
consent what's consent stems from
to me
it's respect
personal respect
because if you don't have
personal respect you can never respect
another
so
if a
human
does not
like themselves take care of themselves
is not happy with themselves that is
going to be exactly what they put out
and so consent while it's
incredibly important
i think as a society we actually need to
go deeper because
we wouldn't be dealing with consent
if you and i respected if i respected
myself and you respected yourself
meaning at large yeah like
yeah because then when someone says
ah
no thanks
it's not personal yes and you respect
that person's yeah desire
yeah
uh declaration opinion like exactly it's
about
being secure in yourself and if we had
humans that were secure in themselves i
really believe we would experience far
less bullying abuse
assault all of it
yeah that's that's that's a that's a
great
perspective on it agreed yeah
gosh
yeah it's just it seems it seems like
such a yeah such a simple thing to
respect
someone else's
sovereignty in the way that they say
that they
are not interested in just
is it though
do most people
[Music]
do most people
live there like follow their own desires
trust themselves do most people
do people trust themselves
no
not really
do most people
actually live there alive in a way that
they that is fulfilling to them
i don't know
we we all think we wouldn't
we wouldn't perform the same
catastrophic actions as a
as an auschwitz guard but
due to the environmental circumstances
that we may be under that it's hard to
say if we would
or not and so for example if you take
the trauma of someone like
potentially the person that
um that violated your consent that it's
hard to say that you would
be a better person
because there is something so traumatic
buried inside that hurt hurts hurt yeah
yeah and i don't
he didn't just
violate my
consent he violated my mind
my womb my body
my blood
my dreams
my ability to have a period
he violated
my trust in myself my trust in every
single human i encountered
for years
trauma affects every single area of our
lives and so does the healing
and
it goes back to
hurt people hurt people
and i also have to imagine that somebody
who can
do that like you brought up the
auschwitz guard somebody who's capable
of
this
level of treatment
they learned it from somewhere
i have to assume
like their environment you have some
stimuli from uh
potentially transgenerational
potentially from tv or music or wherever
else yeah
yeah um
so there's there's it's crazy how you
talked about the also the violation of
the mind and the dreams um there's a lot
yeah you draw it's deeper it's like a
multi
it's a multi
uh faceted and multi-year um
in integration of trauma for healing and
so you're you've you know and this is
also
there's different
trauma comes in different uh ways
there's a significant consensual
violation um
and and rape there's um like an abuse
there's just like a physical abuse um
maybe of like of a hitting or something
like that of that kind of a trauma um
but the mind and the body don't actually
register it that way
humans do that humans put the titles on
it ins from a scientific
medical
perspective
trauma's trauma doesn't matter if it
came sexually it doesn't i don't see it
doesn't matter except makes me sound
super insensitive but
according to the chemicals produced in
your brain
it's not different
so
i mean continue but that's important so
so um
what's do we know like a neurological or
like physiological change that trauma
makes on the physical matter of the
brain
the physical matter
i'm not sure i know that trauma um
disrupts sleeping patterns it changes
organ function it impacts um
communication it impacts
i mean
we are holistic creatures yeah so
everything
everything has cause and effect
and
drama is not excused from that natural
law so it bleeds into every area of your
life yeah yeah i see what you're saying
on sleep and communication and all these
things that are affected
um
okay and and then
um
it's it's
crazy to think that a
like a that of like a physical abuse
and like a sexual abuse
can have a
can have a almost same
traumatic effect on the mind even though
they're
like different in a huge
way
that's
yeah ptsd is ptsd
interesting
so so then is the fresh so fresh what
you what you what you're making and have
made
and available on on the website which is
the links in the bio
that
that walks through all different
any any any kind of ptsd any kind of
trauma
integration uh no fresh is
uh an e guide for your starting point
post sexual abuse post only sexual so
not not physical
it's only only sexual
um
it's only for sexual abuse asexual okay
okay gosh yeah because it's how to file
a sexual assault report it's
great it's
yeah so some of that blends over though
into physical like who to tell how to
file a police
against just physical as well so there's
some bleed over i guess yeah yeah yeah
some overlap um
wow
um okay now
so now so now how do you like tell us
about your like
you know
you started us off with uh
reporting it gave you power and then and
then where did the power uh how did the
power
how did you integrate the trauma and
overcome
the adversity to even start going and
and
being very powerful with your story and
leveraging that like your pendulum swing
tell us about your pendulum swing and
then how you went and even started
helping others yeah oh good
um
uh
well
what fueled me in the beginning was
um
it's a bad word
say it okay yeah
uh was just a very big [ __ ] you
was all i
felt and
i felt
so much shame and guilt and and like
it was it was crippling and i remember
thinking
pretty immediate after the event
what if
what if this happened to someone else
what if he did this again
and then like i just felt like i felt
like my chest was caving in and i felt
like if i didn't do something i would be
helping him
do it to someone else
and
that
like even now like my body just wants to
like
crawl like i just
so
what
that was my driving force for a very
long time
um
was
a lot of anger
and
the determination to make sure he never
did it again
and
most
assailants
are repeat offenders
because we're not reporting them because
we're not getting in trouble because
we're not making them change
and so the thought of me
not doing everything that i could
like that would that would have ruined
my life
so
for um
the next two
years i was basically silent because i
was so
afraid of
burdening anyone
and i really did not want anyone's pity
so
other than my detective because i had
filed a criminal lawsuit
my detective and a couple other people
like involved
in the case
i basically did not tell anyone i had a
partner at the time and he was wonderful
he was my backbone through the entire
process and i am
eternally grateful for him
but
i really
i didn't allow myself to begin to heal
because i was holding everything in i
was holding the trauma in with my voice
with
um not being honest i
and and because i felt like
all i had was my anger
that if i let go of that what would i
have
and that was very scary
um
and that drove me for about two two and
a half years and then i had stress
induced hemorrhaging from my vulva that
hospitalized me twice
and
i remember
i was like in and out of consciousness
but
i i don't know if this actually happened
in real life but it happened
in my reality where i i thought i felt
like one of the nurses or doctors or
someone who was a man
like
grabbing my shoulders and being like
you need
to figure out how to share you need
like you are i think i was 22 at the
time 23 or something
you are so young this should not defeat
you you need
and i remember
leaving the hospital and going well i
don't know what to do because i had been
in talk therapy but that for me was not
helpful
because i was already in my head
i was analyzing everything i was keeping
myself safe as hell i didn't trust
anyone i was on top i was so vigilant
with all of life like i had i had like
nine hamster wheels going in my head
managing every single situation trying
to keep myself safe
i didn't need to be in my head
i completely disconnected from my body i
had zero emotions because they all
freaked me out
and i didn't know how to process them so
i needed something else
and while i know therapy is very helpful
for a lot of people and i'm grateful for
it
it's still true that it didn't help me
um
so after the after being hospitalized
i
i had decided that i would do whatever
it takes
to heal because i was not going
to let this man ruin my entire life yeah
like 70 more years of happy potential
happy flourishing life yeah yeah and i
didn't know how i was going to do it but
it didn't matter i was so determined
to go to the ends of the earth to find
it to swing your pendulum to the
opposite side quickly and
yeah interesting even just even just
saying that is like
how does you know how does one do that
you know how does one swing it quickly
and you gotta you gotta
you gotta have a lot of crazy yeah yeah
i fully owned my crazy youtube yeah yeah
yeah like it's the only reason like
that's the only way this got done
because i was crazy enough to be like
no yeah no i'm tired of my nightmares
i'm tired of not being able to have sex
i'm tired of not like looking in the
mirror and seeing my rapist i am tired
of not being able to trust anyone i am
going to figure
this out if it kills me because it's the
rapes and like all of the ptsd and the
side effects is going to kill me or i'm
going to die trying to figure out how to
be happy and
[Music]
thank god
yeah i can i i it's actually just
thinking about the amount of cortisol
stress over and over again
just traumatically
replaying
and being fearful that that would be
so
bad on one's health
so bad oh yeah on one's flourishing so
to swing back the pendulum and figure
out how to help it's like two things is
figuring out how to a prevent this in
the first place
preventing assault and rape in the first
place and then two is when
when in these circumstances to figure
out how to swing the pendulum back fast
for all trauma this can somewhat be
applied to like the trauma experience
from maybe like a very close like friend
or parent dying um something like
another trauma of sorts that people
experience and like
to to replay like a death over and over
again versus to swing a pendulum back
over quicker this is kind of this is a
good analogy i think yeah
yeah so it's
so your specific pendulum swing you
roared and you were crazy and it was
crazy yeah totally i uh it was crazy i
left um my former career and i literally
went to the ends of the earth
where i was met
by the most incredible souls
i
studied sacred sacred ancient body work
i
um
sat with
grandmothers in their
in in indigenous tribes going through
ceremony i sat around fires and was
blessed by
native women i i gazed with infants i
did yoga meditation
trauma release breath work i did
dance therapy i
i lived in hawaii for three months and
and
got my hands in the dirt every day
because it made me feel alive like there
was nothing that i didn't do and that is
when i realized
that there's no separation between
anything
and so if trauma hits every layer of our
being then the healing has to hit every
layer of our being and that's sexually
emotionally physically healing
intellectually healing cellularly
healing ancestrally healing to get
back to bliss
so i
studied
and my my entire life was dedicated to
healing
for
another maybe two years timeline's not
really my thing um
but another two years and
then i just naturally fell into
sharing
what i had been gifted
and now i see
the importance and the impact
of
sharing and healing and
getting back to the life that we love
um
and that it's always worth it
so that's my like
yeah this when you work now you you
illustrate this you know if trauma hits
all these different parts of our life
then healing has to hit all these
different parts of our life
how do you go about
you know you listed this incredible like
you know hands in the dirt body work
infants grandmothers like you know like
that's yeah you you know all over
healing all over now
does that same style applied to the
people you do one-on-one coaching with
through this healing process how does
that work how do you like
how do you deal with a client's trauma
and then help them through the process
of healing
i currently have
two ways that i get
the privilege of working with people
one is an immersion and then one is
hourly like regular hourly sessions
so with the immersion it is a deep dive
um
it's 48 hours they go off the grid
and
we
meet
everything that arises um and we
do the work and people leave with
total
transformation they leave in their power
they leave knowing how to address every
issue that comes to them they leave more
connected to their bodies and their joy
again and feeling able to feel safe
again they
leave able to
communicate and feel powerful and clear
and just in their communication
it's
the biggest gift of my life every time i
get to work with someone it changes me
like i am
so humbled by it
um and so in that it's it's
we work with all seven bodies so there
are
you know you're there's
the most modern talk therapy practices
we address
you know the primal limbic and cortical
aspects of the brain we
re-pattern
very old limiting beliefs
we get you into your body there's
there's breath work there is um
uh body practices i also do
um the sacred
body work which is like
um it's it's like a three-hour massage
um
there's energy practices for people who
are open to it we
there are spiritual releases like
there's nothing that we don't do
um
because they're worth it because their
life is it matters
um and then in the coaching
it's a lot of the same
practices
um
but broken you know it's less of an
immersion and a deep dive and it's more
of a drawn out journey
and
so
that's how
that's how i'm able to help
this is it's a catalyzing the healing
all over and then you
do like a 48-hour
immersion as the first
process with them
yeah typically
and then it's a kind of like a per case
uh basis of figuring out if they need to
check in like for a couple hours at a
later time like in a couple days or
something like that yeah well in the
immersion because it is such a
transformation and they need we need
time to integrate um
part of that package is a couple of
follow up
either in person if they're close enough
or virtual sessions to really help them
like ground and make it
uh a real part of their lives and to not
just go from this
deep awakening to i'm right back to my
patterns like the reason why it works is
because it's so practical
and broken down so that when they leave
they have tools to meet every moment
and
but it's also a lifelong journey that we
do need support on yeah so
what would be some
of the
major takeaways for you from the
hundreds of people that you've helped in
the one-on-one
coachings
major takeaways
oh i'm getting like um
i'm like seeing so many faces
and i just see everyone smiling with
tears in their eyes
and it i think it means i know that it's
meant something different for every one
of them but it
is that true moment of like
like i can breathe again
and it's
it's that moment of them getting exactly
what they need
whoa so
it's probably not answering your
question no it is that's that is it is
that's a huge takeaway it's just
it it really resonates because
i can't imagine 70 years of not
of living a completely different life
because i wasn't able to swing back a
pendulum um yeah yeah so
to when you do get it swung back and
that like you're saying this this this
arises of that
the tears and the huge smile that that
it's good we have fun we have fun while
we do it too you do yeah
sometimes we garden sometimes there's
art involved sometimes there's tantric
practices like it gets fun
yeah
you have to be like playful like this
and it's so hard for me to
to laugh during this and but i'm glad
that you're you know we
on you are helping people heal you are
giving people the opportunity to come
back to life to feel again to have
better sex to be more confident you are
helping people
like that like
as a survivor please hear that you are
helping us and you're making a positive
difference and that's a lot to feel lied
about
okay
okay
i hope to
do better at that and better understand
how exactly i do that and help other
people do that as well so
it means a lot to to me and hopefully to
just it's just yeah thank you and just
again i just i just i can't
it's hard to even process all of this
really so yeah i think for me it's
people
humans
we're not super motivated to do
something
when
it feels heavy
we're not sure we can do it we're not
sure how to do it
it like the the mountain just like
stacks
but what is that perspective
costing us
because our thoughts are our first
reality and you are choosing not you
specifically but you are choosing
heaviness
when what we the perspective we could
have on this is
you can do it
you can do it and we're gonna change
rape and sexual violence around the
world and it is not
it's not the hardest thing you're gonna
have to do
the assault
was the hardest thing you will have to
do the healing
it's not the hardest thing living with
the assault that's the hardest thing
healing from it not
but we don't
hear that enough
and so when as a survivor when i'm
looking at my options it's like
humans are motivated when they feel like
they can and they know how and
we're not otherwise
jesus
there's a lot of rhetoric that just
occurs in the political sphere about
about this and it's just kind of like
you just want to ask
so you just want to ask
people to
spend a couple hours talking to someone
that has had sexual assault because then
i think they gain more empathy
because otherwise
people just speak about others
without
getting behind their eyes really well
and i'm a huge yeah uh
i i accidentally do this and i aim to
correct my behaviors because if i ever
speak about
someone without sitting down with them
for a long
conversation
like this this conversation changed the
way that i think about
this subject for the rest of my life and
so if we have more
people sit down for an hour and talk
to someone that has went through this
process i think it will drive a lot more
empathy and good behavior
just you want to meet everyone hi luna
come here come on the show come here
come on this show kahuna
i'm here
so this is luna
this is my baby girl
this is my baby girl and she loves you
very very very much hanena this
three-month-old
beauty little peanut here you say right
here
um
to what you were saying about
empathy
um empathy is powerful
there is also no teacher
like personal experience
and i say that because whether or not
you
or not you have directly experienced
the sexual abuse
i can almost guarantee you have
experienced the effects of sexual abuse
so it does
like i believe that
it the ripple effect has has reached
everyone
we haven't we have
depression anxiety we
because of old ptsd we have
um
people who are not in touch with their
sexuality or able to
um
have orgasms
because they're so disconnected from
their body because of sexual abuse so
what if what if your girlfriend has
experienced a sexual abuse when you're
the part you're the partner or her
boyfriend well that affects you too
that affects your your intimate
connection that effect like it does
affect everyone so yes
let's have empathy and also let's look
at how it affects
me
because i i do believe that that our
experiences are our greatest teachers
and it's reached everyone
so that's my opinion
yeah i i agree there's a big
cultural
just big memes
uh
moving around in culture right now about
this um huge memes huge and
it's a
memes are those pictures with the
captions on it
what does it mean
uh just like uh
information that's disseminated through
culture is what a meme is oh god that's
totally not
well it's what mimetics is so that's why
it is called a meme when you take an
image and put a caption on it it's still
called a meme but a memes are at a or a
definitional level is just information
disseminated through culture got it yeah
okay so
yeah so these are like ideas moving
through culture is this yeah yeah that
is that is yeah
original uh yeah
um so
so
holy cow
um
i look how this is good yeah look how
you're doing it we're doing it yeah i'm
i'm
i'm like i guess i got i guess i got
broken and pieced back together so many
times in this conversation
welcome welcome to life man
normally people don't break me and piece
me but i didn't get piece back together
no
like normally that doesn't happen
i just i really yeah i think it was
really important to you know to melt
into
into this with with full
with full presence and energy and
yeah i just yeah just getting
you know with all these practices of
trying to get behind the eyes of you
know of mothers that went through the
process of carrying their child for nine
months and then delivering them
and then trying to get behind the eyes
of people that have actually survived
a serious sexual assault like
that's another one of those things
that's like
when you really go through those
experiences when you really go through
trying to push yourself behind the eyes
of those that are experiencing that then
yeah can you just lightly toss around
these things yeah but you also you're
good you're good
uh a one-on-one coach in that sense
because you you can go between the the
ups and downs on the
on the seriousness and then the
playfulness series playful yeah yeah i
mean one of my
best
therapeutic practices
for
curing myself of uh sleep deprivation
and night terrors
was watching i love lucy like i watched
it every night because
i needed to go to bed light i needed to
go to bed laughing if i woke up in the
middle of the night i needed something
funny because laughter is the best
medicine and i know it sounds so
juvenile and and
like
i i've never heard any doctor prescribe
i love lucy but like
from a real life
experience
i love lucy
what's my best medicine
i wonder
what
this is very interesting because comedy
as medicine
um or potentially like other like
uh
psychedelics
psychedelic psychotherapy potentially as
medicine for
as treatment as therapy for
ptsd yeah totally um yeah so powerful we
have doctors that are now working with
mdma yeah um
i have worked with other shout out to
maps shout out to maps
thanks guys
thank you
um
yeah man
my psychedelic
therapeutic journeys
none compare
and then does psychedelics play an
occasional role in the therapies
for you yeah yeah um
it is an offering
um
and
because
life is so personal
and
the healing journey
is there are no two healing journeys
alike
um
there are no two humans alike there are
no two experiences alike and so i
at the core of my practice it is to
to serve you in the highest way
um so
every every
journey is different but yeah no i do
that has been a huge part of my
healing i'm grateful
to the doctors and the chemists and
mother nature
for giving us that life
and yeah
it's very very helpful
so there's the one-on-one coaching
then there is the fresh this this
the
the electronic immediate response
kit
then there's also the
the courses the retreats that you do as
well so that's all you know cocoa
mckenzie.com check it out
um
i want to let's walk through
some of these sort of like end and
topics um let's do this because you've
you know you've been teaching me a lot
about spirituality and this is very
exciting stuff like you were teaching me
a lot about the womb and teaching me a
lot about creation
yeah
yeah
being the highest only the best thing
ever
i i mentioned the womb so like several
times about giving like birth and
carrying a child like that's a very very
serious
serious thing um
like getting
understanding it biologically about
what's actually occurring inside of a
woman for those nine months as that
child is
literally developing inside of her um
and then yeah coming biologically
spiritually cellularly yes
emotionally
yeah it's interesting yeah all of it
teach us about this this is very
interesting no i don't i don't i don't
know what to teach you i just i
creation's the highest intelligence
teach us about that like teach us about
that
[Laughter]
my room is getting so happy hearing you
like hearing a man be like the womb the
womb is like the ultimate creation
everything is from the woman goes back
to the womb yes
[Music]
yeah it's i mean everything comes from
from
like black from the depths that's where
that is our creative
life force energy
nothing
nothing would exist
without the womb without a a
holding a container
of the sacred
and
it's
and it's also the source of all life and
life is very light and it's beautiful
and it's joyous and it's filled with
bliss
and it is
beautiful
and
our ultimate gift all of us can be
grateful for life itself and we can look
to a woman
for ushering us in
and
i don't i don't mess i worship the womb
100
what is
this this this darkness
when there's no light in the womb
and then the
the life
coming from the womb this is just this
is all
yeah it's the it is the
the great void that is also total and
limitless expansion at the same time
you look at you can compare it
to the galaxies
like
a all of life has that
capacity
and it is stored in our room and
all of life
begins
as female
all of life begins as receptive the
receiver
and
it isn't until
a couple weeks
a couple weeks in
that that changes
but
it's
i don't know how to say it
it's the beginning and the end it's the
alpha and the omega it's
it's it is the ultimate
and
and we all start there
and so it is interesting to see what
great violation
we have done to mother earth
to
our own mothers to
our sisters to
to
the feminine within men
um
yeah
yeah i feel more
yeah i feel like i've been
moving more towards that on the spectrum
throughout this talk and it's been very
important for me to do that
moving more towards what towards
feminine on this during this talk on the
spectrum and that's been it's been very
good and powerful for me
it yeah it would
yeah yeah
i mean one of the biggest
gifts i was
given um through darcy bingham who's one
of my
chosen mothers
um
it was probably 2 a.m
sitting around a fire
and i had she
like
kind of
she led me backwards
and i came to the realization that my
greatest power
is my softness
my greatest strength is my vulnerability
and when like when that clicked
yeah
yeah i think i think that's very true
that may even be applicable for all
people is to unlock their own
vulnerability to unlock their own
allowing emotion to to feel their
deepest emotion guys emotions are how we
know we're alive
okay
emotions are our life yeah that's it's
actually and
before we are male or female
we are [ __ ] humans
we're human yeah yeah we don't have a
gender we are alive we are sensitive
creatures we are capable of
incomprehensible things
to great depths
we're alive we're human we're a species
we are not a gender
and because of this weird
power play and
men visibly show and women don't like
this weird thing that humans have done
over the ages it's caused a lot of pain
and suffering
but if we could just take that away
and re and treat each other as a life as
life as humans yeah yeah that's right
i i do
completely agree that unity and this
collective mentality of
of of humans moving forward is so
crucial um teach us about
god being within us versus
outside of us
um
gosh i have such
my humor i need to filter my humor um i
was
raised in a
fundamentalist
christian background
um
and i am only speaking from my personal
experience i'm not
i am not making any of these statements
like a blanket statement for any
religion
at all but for me
what i took from that from learning that
god was
you know jesus was this
human without sin and and god is this
man this distant man
that
i'm like
just lucky enough that i was
birthed into a family that
had been given god like oh my god what
how lucky am i that i'm one who gets to
of all the seven billion people on the
earth i'm so lucky that my family knew
about god
and
that was so
disempowering for me
because it put my power outside of
myself
and i am never
without my power i am alive i am
sovereign
i am here
and when i
healed
when i got my head heart and body
together and in communication it
turned a switch on where i realized
we are all god god is within us
i am god you are god
and
we we are not i am not i don't have to
ask a man in the sky
to please hear me i hear me i will meet
my needs i will be with my inner child
when she's crying
i will empower the woman within me to
use her voice and speak up truth i
will show up in a loving way
i
am the creator
and that's within everyone
and so going from the place of giving
away my pa the biggest switch for me was
going
from giving away my power to fully
tapping into the power within
and
that's a
a game changer
for me i
know i know that religion has been a
beautiful thing for
countless people i'm only speaking
experience but i think it's really
important to talk about
god as something that is
that is that is
all around us within us all that is love
consciousness these different
definitions of god that are not
necessarily man in the sky type
definition because that is
i think that is closer to the truth
and of what god actually is
and yeah we'll uh we'll see how the
the things evolve in the future
um of like religion and and um
and our definitions of god
what what are these um what are these
what are these seven bodies of existence
you started talking about them in like
dense density physical emotional
intellectual yeah keep going cellular
ancestral
physical
emotional intellectual
yeah physical intellectual emotional
ancestral cellular spiritual bliss
spiritual thank you bless yeah yes so
what yeah so what are these seven
bodies of existence
um and what's density mean like this is
physical so it's like wood and like skin
and like body but then like bliss is
like
overwhelmingly like sensational inside
of me or ethereals can't be described
with words
so there's no density
i'm like one percent the way there
i mean it's so hard to explain um and
i'm not even
i'm not even all the way there um
so this foot will never be
everything's upside down inside out and
backwards
um
okay so the seven bodies
you so
we'll just kind of walk our way through
you have a physical body yes that's yes
undeniable you believe you're here yes
you have an intellectual body you have
thoughts you like you can hear yourself
talking to yourself it's going all day
long it's intelligent it's deep it's
right you have an emotional body
um
you have an ancestral lineage that is
connecting you
that is your past that is where you come
from that that my cells my dna i have an
ancestral body
um
you have a spiritual body
which is a bit
um
it's less restrictive
well than the physical than this
in this way yeah then this density so
everything's energy
again there's
scale and different wavelengths and you
know we're still discovering more and
more and more but
your physicality
is is denser and your
bliss
body and your spiritual body
are higher
in
frequency and therefore able to reach
farther
they don't
know the limits
of the physical realms
and everyone has that if you are alive
you have that and it is about
developing your
tool belt
in each layer of life
that will help you feel more capable and
alive
and true and powerful and
sexual and blissful
the things that we're all
in our physical bodies with our
intellectual minds trying to get to
it's backwards
we can't the tiny mind cannot comprehend
the expanse
of our spiritual body and our bliss
bodies and
even sexuality you you know you're
you will have
better sex
when you get out of your mind
your mind can't fully comprehend like
let the mind go and let the body
experience let it be swept away so
as humans especially americans in
today's society we really really
treasure
the intellectual mind
and it's
valuable it's treasurable it deserves it
um but not at the expense
of the rest of who you are
um
so i don't know okay yeah that's that's
at least getting us to think in seven
different you know at least because
versus just walking around not even
contemplating these seven at least there
is a difference between you know a
physical and you know an intellectual
and an emotional when when i saw um
burden of genius and at the very end
when um
um
when
i i really had like a big epiphany about
uh dr thomas starcell and the work that
he did in order to make organ
transplanting so
widely
able to happen across the world
and just the hard work that he did in
order to make it happen and so many
others that helped him do it i mean i
was
i was it was very interesting i had a
moment when i started just like
just like really like the emotions came
and it was just so profoundly emotional
for me and there was this interesting
moment where my brain tried to turn it
like or my my being tried to turn it off
and i like kind of like grabbed my head
to try and like like to turn the valve
off
it was really fascinating and then i was
like no way and then i like let it go
like like waterfall
i just started sobbing and like and like
really feeling what it was like to and
actually if i would have like i really
strongly think that that
intellectualizing would have i would
have lost the true
feeling of what i was trying to um
experience in that moment which was that
deep profound connection to the to the
difficulty that all those humans went
through to make organ transplanting as
prominent as it is today and saving as
many lives it is today by by turning
that valve off it would have yeah so i'm
this is just you know the emotional body
and then all the way up to you know the
spiritual and bliss the bliss bodies i
think bliss and this ultimate spiritual
body at least some of the all part of
the ultimate spirit in bliss comes from
being in flow when you're in such deep
uh
it's like the most deepest cognitive
instinct is is when you're just lose
track of time and everything else and
you're just hammering out what you love
doing and
and so um that's
and yeah whatever exists past the 3d
realms
so much so much okay let's get to these
five let's get to these final questions
because we could talk forever um
let's uh
let's ask you what is a core driving
principle of yours
i see it as
this
golden pillar of
life giving light
it's the place that i create from it's
the place that i go to inside of myself
it's my first
source it is what i believe is
infinite source
yeah i imagined uh
like
i don't know why but just complete
whiteness and then a big golden pillar
yeah
yeah that's cool that's cool and just
radiating
yeah light life
yeah life
yeah light yeah
that's a good question i actually hadn't
that's a cool one you can see yourself
well i had done that
instinctually
automatically
but i've never had to articulate that to
someone
that's what we try and do
that's what we're trying to do
to get these get this heart to come out
in new ways yeah
how about if you could
re-build civilization from scratch how
would you design it
i would give everyone a little luna
i would give everyone a little luna
puppy
the the
animal therapy
yeah hashtag puppy therapy therapy um
oh god that's okay what's the question
again how would i redesign society yeah
how would you rebuild civilization from
scratch
um i would take out a lot of terms
so
in our human like i see
humans interacting
without these limiting
terms these beliefs
that
create over time have created power
struggle and they've created separation
and they've created
you versus me and if
those
terms that terminology that way of
thinking was not there
i believe we would remember
that we're all one
and you would be without them
um so like some of the terms that
uh that
that um that have pushed us more towards
the
the the illusion that we are separate
from each other and i hate that illusion
yeah me too me too yeah deep meditation
and psychedelics have really destroyed
that barrier
um and made it
makes makes it understand that we are
not separate that we are one
um
interesting cool and then how about
this is simulation so we're going to ask
you are we in a simulation
you know
sure
sure we're in a simulation and
i've got the power
so sure
like yeah yeah you'd be leveling up like
sure
it's one of those it's one of those
things to me that's like all right i
have to choose between a belief i have
to
choose between two things and one of
them i'm gonna believe
which one makes me feel more powerful
which one makes me believe
that i can
okay fine sure we're in a simulation and
i'm god
i don't know how to answer that question
other than that
so then mine my own as well and i'm god
and mine and that we're yeah yeah yeah
interesting that's what i'm going to do
we're god's in our own simulations that
we're leveling up and yeah yes i love it
great
i love it so okay so we're approaching
the exponential technology and
automation age so what do we have what's
a good thing to teach kids
technology and automation age
for the kids what do the kids need to
know
but their human bodies
is where all of this originated from
that their true life
is what created
is what made the creation of
technology possible
that's what i got for you today that
that was really good that was really
good yes holy cow
um
yeah that's
because without that without this yeah
without this evolutionary step of life
the
exponential technology and artificial
general intelligence ages that we're
jumping into they couldn't be here
without life without those biological
forms that that made that
yeah because dinosaurs and chimpanzees
and
and little
multi-cellular ocean
dwelling organisms would not have made
agi so this is that's very interesting
as you point that out so always remember
huh that's kind of cool
always remember yeah that's cool yeah
okay and then last question is what do
you think's the most beautiful thing in
the world
you
you every human
you are the most beautiful thing in the
world
and luna
you
are the most beautiful thing in the
world
interesting so then that so then the
answer the answer is
you don't point pointed back at at
you so basically
then then every then everything so the
answer is kind of like
you as in everything i am the most
beautiful thing in the world
yeah
you are the most beautiful thing in the
world
human life is the most beautiful thing
in the world
yeah it's just beyond
comprehension how blessed we are to have
life evolved here and
it's just also just yeah anyway it can
it can we could go for another hour
talking about how how
just incredible it is that we have
evolved here and yet how
how crazy it is some of the
um some of the things that we talked
about in this episode how some of those
things happen it's like yeah how how
blessed are we that we're here but yet
we have things that we act that we do
that
caused such
yeah such
this trauma is coco this is we're
creating the simulation
this has been such a pleasure cocaine
thank you
yeah thank you it's been very
enlightening
again just shattered and pieced back
together multiple times yeah
yeah thank you thank you for coming on
to the show thank you thank you
there's so so much distill um
get behind the eyes i can't i can't
reiterate it enough you know get behind
the eyes of other people as well as as
well and as often as you can to
understand their complex life journeys
of what got them to where they're at
um for not only the 100 billion people
that lived and died before us to build
civilization but also when you're
talking about some complex political
issue
um like assault
and rape well go and talk to someone
that has actually
been raped or that has been assaulted
and go talk to them for an hour about
their experience before tweeting about
something
so we just need to do a better job at
really going and empathizing because
this has been again just yeah this is
what i think this is what needs to
happen in order to create a deeper sense
of humanity for us across the world
um
and everyone go and you know go and
visit
you know coke mckenzie.com to actually
look at these resources go and check out
fresh and how we can distribute this um
this this
to more people around the world so that
so that at the time of some sort of of
an issue rising like this there can be a
very quick
way to properly
and effectively get through through this
and it's so awesome that things have
evolved way past what it was in 2012 to
2019 of just
the the processes so it's good that
we're that we're evolving these
processes
um give us your thoughts in the comments
below we'd love to hear from you
and
also
you already know but support artists
and entrepreneurs
and
people that are healing
so support cogos for people like us all
those links are below
and go and build the future everyone we
love you very much
we love you we do we love you so much
thank you again
go and build create manifest that
destiny into the world much love and
we'll see you soon everyone bye